greenland is this is not the way to save
Greece that's what Christian Democrat
politician volcom mosebach says about
the third Greek bailout so I mean he was
not all that positive about previously
they allowance either but the government
no longer listens to him welcome how do
you do see you come up in welcome to the
DW interview I'm kailash bah mr. Boz
Bach you predicted quite accurately how
things would develop in Greece how does
it feel that you were perhaps right but
no one seems to be listening it has
taught about kind of a stupa comped
Jimmy as the news by Kate for Greenland
ha I voted in favor of the first rescue
package for Greece unlike other
colleagues who said no from the
beginning I hope that the plan would
work with financial aid being
administered step by step in exchange
for reforms it would put the country
back in a position to finance itself but
the situation has become more and more
difficult then z if you've tried several
times in vain to change things how much
sense does it make to continue in must
us know why that's alonso beyond
austrian v9e well I don't know that in a
few years we said back then that the
second bailout package wouldn't be
enough and there would have to be a
third for that cause trouble he's now a
third package has been approved anyone
who now says mark my words Greece will
need new funds again in a few years will
be criticized just like back then it's
something like being in the groundhog
day movie but I know that in the end
it's not a matter of who's right but who
commands the majority today's gonna be
hunting me I'd DM Z it can get clear you
don't have that you've already said I
don't want to be the big bad bear I
don't want to be the cow that keeps
kicking over the pail of milk you're
considering giving up how unfair does
that same when you see your predictions
realized when it seems you were right be
not they're completely really there I
know the majority's are than the
parliamentary party I don't have any
illusions at all I know that there are
many colleagues who share my views but
nevertheless say yes yeah because
for them it's also an expression of
loyalty towards the government I'd like
to support the finance minister in the
Chancellor and express that by saying
yes although they may be as skeptical
about the issue as I free night can also
skip the gestation in diesel if your own
arguments are so strong why do you want
to step down as chairman of the internal
affairs committee also says need a
leading well-advised doesn't because I
know that I don't owe my mandate to the
parliamentary party but to my voters in
the varnish baggage constituency heading
the internal affairs committee is one
thing they owe that to the parliamentary
party I can understand if someone says a
person who is responsible for leadership
and occupies a certain high
parliamentary party office should toe
the line i betray my response is final
I'll resign from the post of chairman
problem solved giving up my seat is
another matter that's got to be
carefully considered and I'm certainly
not giving anything away when I say that
my political allies back home or
anything but pleased about that prospect
some rightly say that the legislative
period is only half over and I was
elected for four years others say we
didn't elect you in spite of your
position on Greece but because of it and
you can't let us down so non vegan diner
hug don't want one spousal mission Tosh
under the apartheid other people on your
party would be happy if you quit the
chairmanship and gave up your seat to
the CDU's general secretary calls your
behavior and presence in the media a
business model isn't it time to stop
when your own people are taking potshots
at you side officer on Wendy I know
noida and zoo and she's also job you
opening well I'm not going to live with
the CDU general secretary said influence
me I find that a completely absurd
statement of opinion he's got a defended
but it doesn't impress me omegle before
we had general secretaries you've got
into arguments with our political rivals
today they pick fights with their own
political allies I don't feel that's
good for the party that's that when you
all go toward yeah I'm sure but you've
had much harsher words directed at you
former Chancellery Minister Rona profilo
said I'm sick at the sight of you end of
quote how hard did that hit you
and easy at sea descoteaux nice those
not as hard as you might think because
it came straight at me not from behind
my back he didn't go and tattle to the
press or leakage or say off the record
or something like that it was a frontal
assault I can handle those well he
apologized the next day and for me it
was over and done with it's worse for me
when people run to the media and people
who say no are made to look like
colleagues who constantly profile
themselves then I get really upset
because it makes it look as if the
people who say no haven't thought the
whole thing through as if they didn't
have any real arguments and just doing
it to be difficult stubborn or whatever
Eddie mandar las vacas gauged why that
means they're not addressing our
arguments at all they just want to
discredit colleagues for me that's far
worse than someone coming straight at
you he isn't leaf limo asan pantel
uncuff on phone via one of an aspect now
we'd like to talk about something that
you've made public you have cancer
wouldn't what you're still active in
politics in teeth in debt how difficult
is all about for you and how are you at
the moment fish Hobica I don't have pain
or symptoms that prevent them from
working demic treatment has side effects
and they're not great but there are
worse things i follow the rules I take
the medication that I need I never miss
a doctor's appointment and as long as it
stays the way it is I've got no
complaints look like I think I as your
illness changed your viewpoint on things
for example do some of the power games
in berlin now seem unimportant than the
secondary ID isn't yeah i'm on vista it
was you get more relaxed priorities
change things that would have upset me
several years ago might still bother me
but i just say hey you've got very
different concerns why get all worked up
about an article or TV program based on
a lot of content invented by some
journalists Gulf language kundus of his
own agenda do you say priorities change
which ones they are give yourself a
bonus you realize how important that is
and maybe family and friends who didn't
see me often in recent years so called
commons in I've got to consider whether
i should travel less illegal with
anything I'm glad about every invitation
I get but for the organizer is just a
couple of hours for me it often means
trips that have me on the go 16 18 hours
a day and I just can't do that anymore
unfortunately lighter dish Brenda nah
that's you're talking about workload
isn't you've been an active full-time
politician for 40 years do you have a
bad conscience when it comes to family
your daughter's a stinking mover vocals
so it's not all that bad because they've
experienced many nice things that they
wouldn't have if I hadn't been in
politics what really makes me quite
regretful is that I can't go back and do
what I missed the big turning point was
the bundestag moved from bond to Berlin
back then I could still sleep at home I
could bring my kids to kindergarten
later to school then I drove on into
bond and I came home again in the
evening the kids were already in bed but
we had breakfast together in the morning
the move from bond to Berlin put an end
to all that I was sorry about it but I
didn't vote on it myself that was all
decided before i entered the bundestag
tims das la independent wonder stock a
convict yeah put a tick master policy
makers who pursue that career as you do
want to make an impact other politicians
of your caliber would have long since
become ministers so why is it that
you're not one Ignis is it because of
you or Angela Merkel I'm me as a Shalini
well it's certainly not because of me I
would have liked to become one and I had
hopes that weren't flights of fancy but
were based on talks that I had back then
once why i thought i'm talking about
2005 but it wasn't to be in life goes on
anyone who believes i'm desperate or
angry that's all nonsense i would have
liked to have gotten the nod but it
didn't happen I haven't gone less
distance or gone slower as a result I've
worked just like I've always done
there's nothing I would rather do than
what i'm doing now and not everyone who
would like to be a minister because
minister
wouldn't vintners all monkeys I'm say
you only took on the role of party
dissident out of disappointment is that
just malicious gossip does his niche
that's not just malicious gossip kids
would say it's downright mean and it's
nonsense because we're talking about
2005 if that argument were true then I
would have put my frustration on hold
for six years and then after those six
years have said now I'm going to act up
baby shabba bookish bezel why would I
have voted for the first bailout package
for Greece that's often overlooked I
didn't say no from the start I said yes
to the first fell out and then i said
this far and no further there was lots
of applause for the speech back then it
was the last time there was so much
applause from the parliamentary party
for a speech of mine about Greece told
me oh so if the arguments are true then
I would have had to vote no in the very
beginning but I'm quite on midnight
remembers your party is your life no not
at all nine what no the party's
important part of my life but it is in
my life but the party has broken almost
every single promise it's made with
respect to Greece there would be no
Greek bailout package no second package
no haircut and there wouldn't be a third
package now either and the IMF isn't on
board how can you still promote this
party tomorrow cuz it's just watch me
yes the lack of reliability is what
bothers me most dan Meyer shonda by I
was already a member of parliament
mermaid abated the introduction of the
euro in the mid-1990s we were still in
bond back find a pot I I know exactly
what my party promised people about the
introduction of the Euro wendys hot dog
and I still believe the commitments we
made back then are correct now a base
will not do this your business or Sunday
but we're going to great lengths now to
explain why everything has to be
different it's with y'all we're talking
less about the economy economy is less
about objective numbers data and facts
cazal to begin it was that way at the
start of the efforts to save a year old
today it's about Europe about
geostrategic questions about the larger
picture for the whole framework of the
debate has shifted dr. Foreman have us
behind ones from mr. boss [ __ ] we always
conclude our interview with three
incomplete state laws we ask our guests
to finish the repeated receipts wagons
with the billions we gave degrees we
could instead dissing you have really
helped Greece redevelop its economic
strength after reverting to its own
currency coughing so it could stand on
its own two feet without us trying to
dictate to the people of Greece how they
should live in Saudi tia incoming Angela
Merkel's cabinet lacks none eat each
state in politics as long as so long as
long as I can and independent of whether
I'm the head of the internal affairs
committee or a member of a Buddhist on
Election Board of stock I've always been
interested in politics and to shape
policy you don't necessarily have to
head a committee but Dean cause it's not
as all shows a sign of combos bark
thanks for joining us